Một cuộc không gách nhằm vào một chung tiểu học tại Minak.
Tình hôm 1 gà mình nằm nước này, theo phía Iran,
nếu là buộc việc gây thông bong lớn nhất kể được khi Mỹ và Israel phát động chính dịch không biết Iran.
Người phân 1 bùng ngoài giá nước này, ông Asmey, Bà Kai,
gọi góc đòn tâm công là Hải đồng xâm được
và đã cấu thành tổ áp trong nội lãng người khi cố ý nhằm vào một cơ sử dân sử.
Ông Bà Kai yh khẳng định Hải đồng đáp trạc, Iran, Mà Tình Phong về và cạnh báo.
Mọi cua ra hỗ trợ chính dịch của Mỹ và Israel có thể phải chú chính nghiệm theo được pháp của tế.
Về phy Mỹ, ngoài trưởng mất của Rubio Tình Bố,
Washington không có ý nhằm mút tiêu và một chung học và cho biết nếu đời là đòn tận công của Mỹ,
bố trình thành Mỹ sẽ điều tra bố tức là chúng ta Mỹ trước đó tuyên bố đang xem sét cắt mảo gạo về thường vong dân sử.
Về phy Israel đã sinh lúc này tới lý hợp quốc nên đi đàn lên thì nói,
có nhiều mảo gạo khác nhau trong đó có tụi tên cho rằng chính lực lượng về mình cắt mảo hỗ trợ Iran,
e Rogousay mới là bên khai hoa giấm.